♪
I turn on all of
my lights here.
Other than the
brush right there,
I'm driving in a milk bottle.
If this gets any worse,
I'm done.
So, what I'm gonna do is
try to pick my way back,
following my tracks.
The wind and the snow is just
filling them in as rapidly as
I'm making them.
This was just a few minutes ago,
and they're already half full.
I maybe have an hour, I'm
gonna lose all my trail.
I only needed half of a day
to get up to the coast,
get my water, and run back home.
But this winter is what it is,
nature is what it is,
and it said nope.
Here you go.
Hold my beer.
I'm gonna hit her with it now.
I think one of the educational
things I'm getting this year
from the whole planet,
as much as I hate failure,
it's not failure.
It's the ability to recognize
when you need to back down.
I've been full-blown
charging through my life
since I was tiny,
and I think I need a few
of these lessons to go
let's back out of this
before it's too late.
I am glad I turned
around when I did.
There's so much
drifting going on here.
I'm getting turned
around a little.
I can see my barrel,
so I know I'm at the
end of the runway here.
Um, I think I am anyways.
Yeah, here I am.
There.
My garden is there.
Lights are there.
Oh, wow, what
the heck is that?
SUE: Oh, it's my fox.
(bleep).
Scared myself.
What has he got?
Oh, all right.
This is uh...
this is the remnants of a
caribou I got a while back.
Now I got a
couple of foxes here.
I don't have a lot
of caribou left.
I actually want to get out.
They're acting really weird.
That's a pretty
big print there.
Those are pretty big prints.
This is the caribou I got.
I don't know, a
little while ago.
And when I laid it
here, it was all flat.
But I can see right here,
something has snapped the
vertebrae there.
I've got a big hole down here.
I've got a big
hole on that side.
Feel around.
I've got bright
red blood in there.
Yeah, I don't want to
get too involved in that.
What does that?
A wolverine will get on the
underside of the kill,
and like this is,
snap it and pull it under,
snap it and pull it under.
Bury it, pee all over it.
Now look at the snow.
Look at how much I'm getting.
This is all brand new.
That right there is recent.
I don't want to spend my
time in the dark, in a storm,
trying to figure out who's
eating at my table uninvited.
But Kavik is mine.
So, I want to know
who's roaming around in it.
And if it's a big top predator,
I've got to know that.
But right now,
I can't do much.
My hands are
getting bright red.
My temp is really dropping,
the snow is coming in hard.
I want to get home.
And as long as I can see,
get out here and see
who's in my yard.
Who's awake and
doing something.
Cause right now, I'm betting
it's bigger than a fox.